Buenos días la otan ya se prepara para
esta cumbre en vilna la capital de
lituania en que el secretario general de
la otanberg haya avanzado Cuáles van a
ser los puntos principales de esta
reunión para empezar la aprobación de un
plan para que las fuerzas ucranianas
cada vez están más cerca cada vez más
integrada según los estándares de la
otan también se reforzará un consejo
formal entre la otan y también Ucrania
se trata de un foro mucho más formal que
el actual en que la comunicación es
mucho más fluida y también muchísimo más
habitual Y por último como comentabas se
reafirma este compromiso de Ucrania para
convertirse en futuro miembro de la otan
este compromiso ya se había confirmado
en
2008 pero se trata para stalltemberg de
un importante mensaje en que si no en
que se trata sobre todo de dar este
mensaje en que Ucrania puede formar en
el futuro parte de la otan el conflicto
por supuesto ha hecho cambiar todas las
cuestiones pero sin duda también se
trata de que Ucrania cada vez ha estado
más cerca de la otan cada vez este
proceso ha sido cada vez más
Irreversible en esta última Cumbre
también se pidieron a los Estados
aumentar el gasto al menos en un 2%